[Música]
Gracias por recibirme nos acercamos a
cumplir un año de guerra en Ucrania Así
es el presidente pollonsky cree que
puede ganar esta guerra en el 2023 este
año
hemos oído al presidente francés y al
canciller alemán decir en la conferencia
de seguridad de Múnich que esta será una
guerra larga qué opina al respecto
en vez de decir que Rusia no puede ganar
esta guerra y que Ucrania no puede ser
derrotada creo que deberíamos cambiar el
paradigma
Si queremos tener una paz larga y
duradera debemos decir que Rusia debe
perder esta guerra y que Ucrania debe
ganar esta guerra no solo es la
diferencia semántica es una manera
diferente de abordar esta guerra
por eso Polonia está proponiendo enviar
la mayor cantidad de armas lo más rápido
posible
porque no solo es necesario que Ucrania
se defienda de la próxima ofensiva rusa
sino que debe poder contraatacar
debe poder reconquistar su propio
territorio
por eso este momento es tan crucial en
la historia de Europa
y realmente creo que con nuestra
determinación
[Música]
en 2023 puede terminar esa guerra en
Ucrania y creo que Ucrania ganará esta
guerra
posiblemente este año posiblemente este
año sí según su análisis si Putin no es
detenido o Derrotado como dice en
Ucrania otros países incluidos los
países de la otan incluido Polonia
podrían ser los siguientes
absolutamente
recuerdo las palabras del presidente
en 2008 cuando dijo
ahora Putin está atacando Georgia y
luego si en Ucrania
y después los estados bálticos y quizás
después Polonia
y este escenario se está cumpliendo Solo
que el cráneo está luchando con un
corazón de León por su independencia
pero también por nuestra libertad y por
nuestra seguridad
Por eso creo que esta guerra es
potencialmente una especie de momento
decisivo en la historia del planeta
no solo en esta parte de Europa Creo que
este peligro es muy muy real
Rusia ha invocado a los peores demonios
del siglo 20
el imperialismo el colonialismo y el
nacionalismo
y esas son las bases de su sistema el
Cruise como lo llaman Putin y el kremlin
y es un sistema muy peligroso
ha habido intimidaciones hemos visto que
en el espacio aéreo se han interceptado
algunos aviones rusos muy cerca de las
fronteras ha habido más sucesos así
absolutamente cada vez vemos más
provocaciones así son muy visibles pero
voy a decirle algo que no es muy visible
y que es muy peligroso para Francia para
Polonia para toda Europa
rusa es enorme
es difícil que la gente en Francia en
España y en Alemania Imagine lo efectiva
que es
lo Arrolladora que es y lo que puede
llegar a hacer
Rusia está invirtiendo mucho en noticias
falsas en redes sociales en propaganda
Y eso también es el arma de guerra
moderna
usted mencionó al presidente selensky
que aquí en Múnich pidió a sus aliados
que acelerarán la entrega de armas hubo
un debate sobre los tanques el canciller
Alemán dijo que estaba listo para el
envío de tanques de opac pero pareciera
que muchos países que dijeron que los
iban a enviar en realidad no lo están
haciendo es esto un problema ahora que
aunque en principio hay un acuerdo en la
práctica de esos tanques no están
llegando a Ucrania
claro la teoría los Los acuerdos deben
ir a la par con la práctica
y recuerdo que mis discusiones con el
canciller shows en diciembre cuando lo
Estaba tratando de persuadir
fue difícil
fue muy difícil en ese momento pero
traté de ver el vaso medio lleno y no me
dio vacío
y me alegra que Alemania finalmente haya
decidido enviar tanques leopard
Aunque es muy modernos a Ucrania ahora
estamos en el proceso de hablar con los
demás
y los finlandeses con el gobierno
finlandés para pedirles que también sean
parte de esta coalición porque este no
es solo un acuerdo general y teórico es
también una realización práctica de este
paso
Polonia está listo para entregar sus 14
tanques leopard Por cierto se suman a
los más de 300 tanques que ya hemos
enviado
que estamos en proceso de entregar a
Ucrania
algunos son tanques bastante modernos
ningún otro país en el mundo le ha dado
más tanques a Ucrania que Polonia
entonces realmente creo que esta
coalición de países que envía tanques
leopard Se pondrá de acuerdo rápidamente
y que los tanques se enviarán a Ucrania
y en el caso de los aviones de combate
Esta es la nueva cuestión ustedes tienen
aviones f-16 alrededor de unos 50 con
este tema ha sido mucho más precavido
que con los tanques ha dicho que debe
ser decisión de la otan también está la
opción de que Polonia envía aviones mig
29 a Ucrania Cuál es su posición
respecto a este tema
tenemos muy pocos aviones de combate en
modelo f-16 como usted dijo y tenemos
mix mix
Polonia puede ser parte de una coalición
de países que envíen aviones de combates
a Ucrania
pero no estamos listos para enviar
nuestros mix
y tampoco para hacerlo por nuestra
cuenta sino como parte de una coalición
más grande
es algo muy importante porque los rusos
están dominando el espacio aéreo
y porque cada vez más cohetes misiles y
bombas
no están alcanzando sus objetivos a
causa de los sistemas antiaéreos
la desproporción entre Ucrania y Rusia
en cuanto a todos los aviones de combate
es tan grande
Ucrania debería recibir apoyo en esta
área
entonces usted enviaría aviones mic en
vez de f-16 no inmediatamente solo como
parte de una coalición más grande como
lo dije Cuáles son las sanciones contra
Rusia se supone que debe haber un nuevo
paquete de sanciones usted ha dicho
varias veces que no es suficiente porque
las sanciones no están afectando la
economía rusa tal como se esperaba
por eso al principio fui Quizás El
Primer Ministro de Europa en haber dicho
que se debían confiscar los bienes rusos
los bienes de la federación rusa y los
bienes de los oligarcas rusos
eso no se ha aceptado No todavía pero
varios países están hablando de manera
cada vez más positiva sobre esto
y si por ejemplo la comisión europea
tomará esa decisión
o estimulará esa toma de decisión
cada vez más países deberían estar de
acuerdo o podrían estar de acuerdo con
un enfoque Así es muy importante
es realista eso
es muy importante darse cuenta de eso
porque eso también significaría que el
país agresor
carga con una responsabilidad muy
directa por todas las pérdidas
y daños causados por sus tropas soy un
gran partidario de esta acción aquí hay
400.000 millones de euros flotando en el
aire como fruta madura como dicen
y deberíamos tomarlos y usarlos con dos
objetivos
deberíamos usarlos para reconstruir
Ucrania
infraestructura energética los
hospitales bombardeados con los rusos
los jardines infantiles y demás
pero también deberíamos usarlos para
reducir las facturas del gas y de la
energía en Europa
porque esta es una consecuencia directa
del ataque ruso a Ucrania
es inflación como le llamamos
una inflación muy alta en toda Europa
esos 400.000 millones de euros están
aquí porque no usarlos
seamos valientes y trabajemos por
soluciones legales
hemos oído al presidente francés
Emmanuel macoa al canciller alemán
olafelds repetir durante meses que es
necesario mantener canales de
comunicación abiertos con Vladimir Putin
cree que están cambiando su postura a
este respecto
veo que están cambiando su enfoque
ahora el presidente francés ha dicho que
las conversaciones son imposibles
listo y que no llevarán a ningún lado
esas son mis palabras por supuesto no
las suyas
es apto de eucariñas pero
definitivamente lo he visto cambiar su
enfoque
sub ucranianos son quienes deben
determinar lo que significa la victoria
pero como dije
yo no quisiera que Rusia esté ganando a
medias esta guerra
porque eso significaría que están
preparando la siguiente fase
que se están preparando para el
siguiente ataque
para la siguiente ofensiva
potencialmente en los Estados bálticos o
en Finlandia o en Polonia o en Rumanía o
en moldavia o en otro país fronterizo en
países del Asia central
por eso este momento es tan crítico y
debemos hacer todo lo posible para que
esta Rusia sea completamente derrotada
porque esto Solo podría crear un nuevo
Punto de partida para una nueva era de
desarrollo
esto implica un cambio de régimen en
Moscú
bueno eso Por supuesto Siempre es
posible pero desafortunadamente no veo
que en Rusia la opinión pública apoya
ampliamente a Putin
Y eso en parte también es por la gran
propaganda tan fuerte
vocal y Arrolladora del propaganda
el presidente biden visitará Polonia el
próximo martes y el miércoles sí sí para
conmemorar de cierta manera el primer
año de guerra en Ucrania simbólico es
esto para Polonia asumo que también
habrá una reunión con el presidente
ucraniano es muy simbólico primero que
todo Estamos muy agradecidos con Estados
Unidos por su determinación de defender
a Ucrania
porque y en eso Podemos ser muy directos
sin Estados Unidos probablemente ya no
habría una Ucrania libre en este punto
Entonces sí el presidente biden no solo
será simbólica sino también muy concreta
hablaremos sobre cómo apoyar de manera
más efectiva y eficiente a Ucrania con
misiones por ejemplo
esto se necesita Con urgencia
actualmente y también con armas para que
Ucrania pueda sacar a los rusos de su
territorio
y el presidente también estará ahí
Espero que el presidente celeste con
nosotros esto también sería muy
simbólico
señor Primer Ministro Muchas gracias por
estar en la entrevista de France 24
Gracias por recibirme Gracias a ustedes
por sintonizar esta entrevista desde
Munich en Alemania
[Música]